allez on continue cette émission avec
notre invité du 7 8 week-end Christine
sauvage bonjour vous êtes libraire un
voisin le Bretonneau votre librairie va
fêter ses dix ans cette année bon
anniversaire mais merci le samedi de
Paris c'est du 22 au 25 mars et du coup
évidemment vous êtes venus nous
présenter une sélection de livres oui
mais pas tout à fait lié au salon
en tout cas cette semaine on va
commencer par l'ombre de la lumière
c'est un livre autour de la vie de
Saint-Augustin
moi Augustin aujourd'hui parce que bon
l'église mais là on le voit sous un
autre aspect Claude pujadrenault revient
sur sa vie de jeune homme un jeune homme
qui aimait bien la vie le vin les femmes
le jeu enfin bon un bon vivant et qui
avait une compagne toute jeune dont il
était follement amoureux et qu'il a donc
garder pendant 15 ans dont il a eu un
fils mais sous l'influence de sa mère il
était maniché c'est-à-dire une secte qui
existait à l'époque mais il y avait
l'expansion du christianisme et entre
autres sa mère Monique une sainte mais
une forte femme semble-t-il aussi un
petit peu
protectrice et voulant garder son fils
la convaincu de se convertir au
christianisme et que ce passatile et
bien
Augustin lâche sa compagne la République
carrément et puis devient le saint que
l'on connaît et Claude Puget
de Saint-Augustin mais donc
c'est vrai que là Claude pujad Renaud
met en lumière cette femme c'est très
jeune femme dont on connaît l'existence
et qui a totalement disparu du jour
Augustin s'est converti et donc elle
imagine elle romance bien sûr la vie de
cette femme et la vie de son fils
d'ailleurs qui disparaît aussi puis lui
a retiré son fils Augustin gardait le
fils mais il a pas gardé la femme donc
dans l'ombre de la laisser très très
gros moment bien écrit bien vraiment
Claude Puget c'est une de nos auteurs
contemporaines les qui écrit le mieux
qui est vraiment une grande hauteur
alors l'ombre de la lumière Claude plus
jade Renault chez Acte Sud on peut dire
qu'avec tout de suite c'est une valeur
sûre oui et puis dans l'édition une
autre valeur sûre rue du monde d'autant
plus local puisque c'est un éditeur de
voisin le Bretonneux pour poules et
poulet
pas résister je n'ai pas résisté parce
que c'est un ouvrage ça paraît juste
avant Pâques et alors les poules quand
même on en parle au moment de Pâques les
couleurs chocolat mais là ce sont des
jeux de mots sur les poules et les
poulets et je ne résiste pas là aussi
c'est des poésies on peut dire dès l'âge
de 8 ans oui même six ans il y a des
jeux de mots il y a 48 poèmes autour de
la poule voilà allez c'est une sauvage
disez-nous un nouveau un des poèmes que
vous avez choisi une poule givrée du
moindre grain de priver du moindre grain
semblait de riz de miettes de pain sans
maïs et sans biscuit sec une poule comme
ça elle claque du bec elle claque du bec
et toute son comme ça c'est vraiment des
jeux de mots des jolis petits devinettes
des petites qui sont qui sont à croquer
donc tout petit poème voilà quelques
petits poèmes à lire à vos enfants à
partir de 6 ans oui
chez Rue du Monde un éditeur qu'on aime
bien et qu'on soutient ici à téléfils
Surcouf pouf ah oui alors on passe là du
vraiment quelque chose complètement
différent de très très belles bandes
dessinées autour d'un personnage d'un
aventurier extraordinaire le prince des
corsaires Surcouf et on part en fait
c'est le récit d'un d'un journaliste en
fait un espion de Sa Majesté et
d'Angleterre qui voulait tuer Surcouf
qui est envoyé vraiment pour le détruire
puisqu'il est en train de rafler les les
plus belles comment les plus beaux
chefs-d'œuvre de la marine
anglaise et en fait il va tomber sous le
charme de cet homme qui est un
aventurier mais aussi un homme de cœur
et donc on découvre à travers ces deux
bandes dessinées la vie du de ce grand
marin de ce malin depuis depuis
effectivement la Bretagne des côtes de
Bretagne jusqu'aux Indes au maire des
Indes et alors il y a un dessin
extraordinaire très très beau que ne
peuvent pas manquer tous les amoureux de
la marine très jolie oui c'est vraiment
très très bien dessiné avec une
précision sur les navires de cette
époque etc sur et puis bon c'est de
l'aventure tout de même à travers les
mers et avec un homme d'une grande
prestance effectivement je sais pas si
on peut montrer je sais pas si on voit
bien c'est magnifique les bateaux voilà
quoi pour ceux qui aiment qui aiment la
Marine en tout cas
on a parlé à poules et poules on a parlé
des poèmes pour les enfants et là on va
parler la transition n'est pas facile
yellow Birds les soldats en Irak alors
du coup des vraiment roman autour
effectivement de la guerre en Irak avec
le retour et le récit d'un soldat qui a
vu mourir deux jeunes qui sont partis
lui avait mourir son son compagnon qui
était presque son frère 21 18 ans et qui
découvre cette guerre terrible et comme
toutes les guerres et qui ne s'en
remettra jamais et qui ne peut pas
oublier celui qui l'a laissé là-bas
et qui arrive à survivre mais qui pour
donner envie aux gens de lire ce livre
parce que c'est pas forcément envie de
se plonger dans une histoire
de solidarité c'est un récit aussi on
voit les soldats qui se serrent les
coudes et puis en face bon c'est vrai
les politiques qui qui ne perçoivent pas
tout ce qui se vit et au quotidien et
c'est vraiment le quotidien de ces
jeunes gens mais qui sont très
attachants et en même temps qu'on voit
petit à petit complètement détruit et
qui arrive difficile reconstruire quand
ils reviennent dans la vie de tous les
jours le quotidien ça on en a parlé et
on oublie aussi ce quotidien de ces
vétérans ces jeunes vétérans qui vont
traîner enfin cette vie toute cette
espèce de mémoire tranchée toute leur
vie donc Kevin power yellow Birds sur la
guerre en Irak et la douleur notamment
la guerre une autre douleur celle de
Françoise Giroud histoire d'une femme
libre ça rend gros c'est un manuscrit
qui est resté
inédit pendant une cinquantaine d'années
c'est ça volontairement volontaire
volontairement parce qu'il touchait à
l'intime parce qu'il toucha des
personnages connus parce que Françoise
Giroud était un peu aussi une icône
féministe journalistique et que bon
c'était un moment vraiment de très
grande faiblesse de cette femme qui a eu
un grand pouvoir
elle tente de se suicider et elle y
parvient presque après une déception
amoureuse
prendre la connaissait pas parce qu'on
connaît la Françoise Giroud flamboyante
voilà mais vous savez pourquoi ce livre
apparaît maintenant parce qu'elle ne
voulait pas elle le sortir et puis que
Alix de Saint-André a fait un peu le
siège des archives qui est ces documents
étaient passés un peu à la trappe ils
étaient dans les archives mais personne
ne les avait exhumé en fait donc à
nouveau visage de Françoise Giroud tout
à fait attachant en même temps
professionnels ça reste une grande
professionnelle tout à fait histoire
d'une famille Françoise Giroud un polar
en ce moment avec le temps qu'il fait au
coin du feu on est bien avec un polar
c'est le conseil de Christine soba donc
au coin du feu si vous avez une cheminée
vous pouvez lire votre honneur ça se
passe aux États-Unis ça se passe aux
États-Unis mais on suit une bon c'est un
Cyril killer bon c'est un méchant le
cerveau c'est un méchant on le retrouve
à travers les les polars de James
Patterson et là bon c'est vraiment
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à au toute dernière
page parce que je l'ai fini en fait hier
soir donc voilà vous ne dites rien non
je dis rien mais mais mais d'ailleurs le
serial killer il continue je vous
rassure il y en a un autre après mais là
oui c'est terrifiant mais il fait des
émules en plus il a des imitateurs
donc j'aime pas de personne en votre
honneur donc on suit nous avions un vrai
roman policier à l'américaine mais mais
plein de ce qui se passe donc recommandé
par Christine sauvage qu'il a fini donc
hier soir au coin du four on a bien
compris allez on finit avec un livre je
sais pas si c'est historique l'ombre
douce mais en tout cas c'est un roman
mais c'est ouvert d'une belle histoire
d'amour ça revient sur
une Indochine en 1954 mais alors c'est
un roman magnifique un roman d'amour
alors ça change un petit peu du policier
ou justement on passe d'un extrême un
peu à l'autre là une toute jeune un ami
qui tombe folle amoureuse d'un jeune
soldat mais lui il est bretons
et malgré toutes les difficultés ils
vont vivre cet amour alors vraiment
c'est la passion folle et avec une
écriture très poétique très simple et
bon ça termine un peu mal bien sûr mais
en même temps
mais c'est vraiment la rencontre de de
civilisations de culture et en même
temps ce que l'amour peut faire
découvrir justement en
malgré ces différences de culture de
vision du monde une belle histoire
d'amour l'ombre douce entre chez Viviane
toujours une des trouvailles Viviane
elle aussi un peu comme Acte Sud elle
trouve des auteurs qui sont un peu
inconnus même carrément inconnus et
quand on découvre à travers une écriture
magnifique d'accord merci pour votre
sélection de livres merci d'être venu
sur ce